what i like about anime is that a lot of
times the medium doesn't shy away from
showing those realities and possible
consequences or lack there of those also
while the forgiveness esop is offering
in a lot of anime often in battle shonen
we also see some key moments when
bullies get their comeuppance it's a
mixed bag though all in all and today
we'll be talking about the latter after
all while i don't promote violence it's
really more fun and satisfying to see
the bullies get what's coming to them
right that's just who a lot of us are
and these bullies do need to be taught a
lesson sometimes you know so strap
yourselves in come with me on a ride
that features anime bullies whether the
schoolyard type or ones outside school
settings get there come up inside
now let's be honest haven't you had that
time when you wanted to strike back at
bullies or people who looked down at you
shigaraki in his younger years took
matches in his own hands and he made
those thugs pay in a show that would
have any kid drunk with power it's these
moments that are both sad and gratifying
no way should those thugs be allowed to
go scot-free with their bullying but
this way of shigeraki following his
heart soon leads him down to the path of
villainy it's truly a tough dilemma if
you ask me him the week shigaraki has
been extinguished and the future symbol
of fear was born in this very moment
it's a chilling moment for two very
contrasting reasons conflicting feelings
on this one but it's something that
drives so close to home
ironically i don't see a silent voice in
a lot of discussion about bullies
getting their comeuppance because it's
an entire movie devoted to the bullying
often times i see a lot of the community
talk about bullies getting their
comeuppance and of all those times this
is the first anime i immediately think
of needless to say our protagonist shoya
gets the worst of it he's definitely not
the only one at fault for shock or
transferring schools but he's the one
who gets the full brunt of the backlash
resulting from it causing his life to go
on a downward spiral shawya getting what
he deserved was the impetus to get the
plot going and set him on his course to
redemption a silent voice by all means
is a beautiful story about human nature
forgiveness and turning a new leaf and
it won't ever be possible if surya
didn't get this on the other hand i feel
that the other classmates got away
scot-free for my liking yep they all
suffered in their own ways in the movie
to varying degrees but how fate and
karma hit them back just doesn't compare
to what shawya had to go through maybe
that's why a sign of voice doesn't get
talked about too often in the topic of
bullying it's a movie instead of a
series and the other bullies don't
suffer nearly enough to pay for their
past behavior
let's continue with a light novel
adaptation with axel world now with a
fatty like that as a protagonist we all
know it's coming sooner or later don't
we ironically enough the moment that
i'll be talking about comes at the final
arc of the anime adaptation yet haruyuki
had experienced a lot of crap with
bullying and being shunned prior to this
but it was naomi seiji who took things
to another level even involving haru's
two friends in this crap manipulation
rumor spreading blackmail some ntr vibes
naomi is pretty much the epitome of a
hate sync if you've seen one he's
rightfully hated by so many people
who've watched this anime but that's
what makes his eventual demise look oh
so satisfying even his supposed sad
backstory doesn't change anything not
when he spent an entire arc gloating
about stealing the protagonist's powers
turning their girl into his side and
bragging about all that he can do with
his powers axel world is one of the
first video game series i've been very
immersed in and at that point i never
felt as much catharsis as seeing chi you
pull the reverse uno card and revealed
that she's been the one playing all the
time just to leech off his skills before
turning back to the good guys side the
whole arc makes seeing naomi's final
groveling form so satisfying just before
he's executed and exiled from the game
for good
tokyo avengers is a curious case while
i'd consider kiyomasa's faction bullies
in the pure sense of the word that's all
to the expectation of them being you
know thugs running a fight club that's
in contrast to the previous examples who
are all students that you shouldn't have
the expectations of being such big
[ __ ] regardless the starting arc of
tokyo revengers really left a bad
impression on me thanks to daki michi's
treatment it's not a bad impression in a
sense of me disliking the show but a bad
impression in a sense that i really
wanted gyomasa to get beat and dakimichi
just tried that in a cliffhanger and
that had me oh so hyped it's the classic
underdog finally rises up against the
bully story turns out it's not our
protagonist who gets the finishing blow
but the dynamic duo of draken and mikey
it feels oh so great to see this scrub
get put in his place by the real head
honchos and it must have been really
humiliating for someone like him who
talks too big it must have felt like a
kick to the balls for kiyomasu and i
mean that quite literally
[Music]
and yes the famous elfin lead scene it's
a scene that's not for the faint of
heart not just because of the violence
but because of the people involved for
the entries that i've listed so far the
perpetrators are either teenagers who
mostly ran their mouth and beat people
up or kids with pranks gone horribly
wrong however none of them come as close
to the heartlessness as these people
from elfin lead and they're kids for
god's sakes 11 year olds i don't think
the kid versions of the silent voice
protagonist would be as heartless as
outright beating lucy's only friend a
dog to death in front of her it's a
level of graphic violence that could
have been laughed as an attempt at being
edgy but that scene legitimately pissed
quite a few viewers off including me so
to no one's surprise no one shed a tear
when lucy unleashed her powers and just
massacred those bullies people say that
violence is never the answer and while
i'd personally prefer a world without
conflict you can't help it when bullied
kids strike back and it's sad to say in
the real world fighting back often in
rather violent ways is also the only way
to stop the whole bullying things a lot
of times realistically speaking
next is fruits basket
i'll tell you a mildly interesting thing
about fruits basket one of the most
beloved shojo series of all time if you
go on youtube and type in fruit basket
one of the first suggestions you'll get
is fruits basket bully scene i guess
that's just how big of a moment this is
for fans of the show and i'm sure a lot
of them get a kick out of watching the
whole thing unfold and i don't blame him
in the slightest episode 22 of the 2019
remake is a rollercoaster of emotions
seeing sarki's entire backstory unfold
just gives us a glimpse of how sick some
children really are i wouldn't be
surprised to know people who found the
live newt scene extremely revolting the
fiasco's not to the brutal extent of the
elfin lead one a while ago but it is
just as bad the sad thing is that i
believe that something like this does
happen in a lot of schools in real life
that's why i couldn't care less about
the boys when saki unleashes her powers
on them in a fit of rage she even tries
holding herself back while doing it the
sad part of this is that she's the one
whose life took a down turn after the
incident and she even gets worse over
time when it comes to the bullies on a
positive note though i think that the
whole chain of experiences makes her
eventual friendship with doru and arisa
all the more heartwarming
[Music]
it's no surprise that one piece will be
in such a personalized list being one of
my favorite series of all time any
guesses as to what moment made the list
why the punch that was heard all over
the world of course i like one piece not
just for the action of the adventure the
wacky powers in the world building but
also for the themes these include the
idealistic ones like friendship as well
as the more serious stuff that can apply
to the real world like racism mind you
it's not a trait that's exclusive to
this beloved shonen series but it sure
does well in presenting those themes
using its extremely colorful world such
as this incident with luffy punching out
the celestial dragon it's pretty much
one of the textbook examples of racism
and bullying on display and even took
place at a grand stage of an orchard
seeing luffy stick up for his buddy and
not caring about the ramifications is a
thing of beauty it takes real guts to do
that not even the celestial dragon
status spared him from this beat down
good for him though he deserved it
that's my personal list of favorite
scenes of bullies getting what they
deserved in anime i'm sure you've got a
lot more to add to this list so i'd like
to hear your input on both the picks i
made and the scenes themselves if you
enjoyed watching the video and would
like to support the channel don't forget
to check out the channel's membership
options you can gain access to even more
videos that way you can also support me
on patreon and it will help me come up
with even better production quality on
these videos as we start moving towards
the channel's next big milestone thank
you for watching and i hope that you had
a lot of fun i wish to see you again on
my next video so see you then
[Music]
[Applause]
you